hey guys we are back again well I mean I
haven't been here yet my name is Jess if
you don't know who I am
you do know Alexa my lovely guest who
was here earlier and we've got John here
you don't know John yet but you will
because he's going to scare the pants
off you because John is here to talk
about here they lie it is not only a
horror game it is a VR hard game yes it
is and we got our first tease of it
right after the Sony conference and I do
mean a tease it was like a collection of
creepy image of setting the tone for
what I'm sure it's gonna be one of the
scariest games I'm gonna have played in
recent years decades yeah I'm so scared
please tell me what I'm in for I need to
know for an VR
a surreal trip down the rabbit hole is
you're following the woman in yellow and
there's there's a lot to the story into
the narrative of this adventure into
this sort of dystopian world we're
really excited to bring into VR just the
strangeness and the the sort of
impossibility of places and in VR we're
able to do that uniquely it's a lot of
fun do you ever get when you're playing
it do you ever get disoriented or like
how like you know well I get to sori
nted no okay oh well you'll get what
we'll want to do is we'll want to take
you know a normal place that you feel
like you would walk through and you get
a sense of it and you feel like this is
a place I know and then we build upon it
being possible so imagine you're walking
down an alley and all of a sudden the
alley starts turning into a cyclopean
city right by create by starting in the
normal place you just kind of disconnect
yourself from reality that becomes way
more powerful when you're walking
through the space like you feel like
you're doing in VR so let's take it from
step one I mean what can you tell us
about who are we in the game what what
kind of narrative structure are we
putting together
well most I can't tell you and it's all
for the player to divert the player is
going to wake up in this strange play
okay as they're following Dana the woman
in yellow right
they're gonna be confronted by different
groups and factions in this world and be
challenged with decisions and moral
choices those things are important
because they're going to help define who
you are as you're playing through the
world and to the end decisions you have
to make so does the game then change
based on what you decide there's there's
some there's some branching in it yet
right that's awesome
so you guys are your team is actually
made up of people who used to work on
like coal of Gd and shoe writer and
stuff what's it like working in a much
smaller studio
well yeah our studio is made up of a
Corey Corey Davis who was the creative
director of SpecOps the line yeah I mean
Corey in rate cops did a lot of when the
moral decisions and making the player be
confronted by the choices in war and
it's so great in the narrative and then
we got Toby Gard the creator of Tomb
Raider Richard Smith and myself who are
Call of Duty and Medal of Honor guy yeah
we had all been making a lot of big
games and it's a lot of fun I certainly
love that big teams you're able to pull
so much to bear on it on a game but we
wanted a project where everybody knew
each other it was taking it from that
big scale into a small band and so we we
finished our last job and we literally
that Sunday showed up in my garage on
tan gentleman yeah it was fun it was it
was it was great and you know like we
had like about six people all power
piled into the garage and Glendale how
big is your team now
now we're 12 to 15 oh well okay oh
that's fantastic and how long have you
been working on this game I'm working on
this game for about a year and a half
Wow okay what is our time when we when
will we see it we're shooting for launch
of the launch window of ER so late fall
VR okay so I mean obviously you guys
have such a history with so many
different genres and different kinds of
games what drove you towards wanting to
make a horror game particularly
psychological horror
sounds pretty dense well it's definitely
in Corey's wheelhouse he's very
comfortable is very comfortable with the
genre
and there's a lot of subjects to explore
and what what we wanted to push was the
surreal the strange and sort of the
eerie and instead of making it about
monster closets and and jump scares we
didn't we weren't looking so much about
let's scream or the Friday the 13th but
we were looking more for like a shining
or right under the skin or beyond the
beyond the black rainbow something more
psychological yeah that us was going to
be where we were the most excited
because there's so much room to play in
there to find the right tone so would
you say it's been more about building
atmosphere and designing monsters
completely about building atmosphere
because we want the horror to sort of
well up inside of you yeah that
discomfort and sense of dread to be
because of all the elements the the how
the world is put together the the how
the elements are interacting with you
once you put on those headphones and
you're in the 3d audio you're able to
send to cue the player two sounds that
are coming from you good right you know
exactly in your head where that sounds
coming from and it really freaks people
out yeah I mean now that you brought it
up we have to talk about via because
obviously horror and via are equally as
made for each other as they are things
that you'd never ever ever go together
with an immediate decision that you
wanted this horror game to be a VR
experience so did that come later it was
um it was pretty early in the process we
were always making the strange horror
and as and this wasn't about to early
2014 and that's when the kit started to
roll out and it became it just kind of
became natural as we were working
through it to realize that this was
going to have a really great home on VR
so um we adapted very quickly and we've
actually been using the it's been since
last January where we've been running on
VR and trying different versions of it
yeah I think that work and trying and
realizing things that don't work and
just adapting as we get to the right
spot I'm just playing this trailer again
the design aesthetic like sometime
it seems a little a little surreal but
then it's very realistic like and then
your color palette goes from dark to
really bright as we're watching right
now so can you just talk about like the
artistic design sure where there's
certainly a lot of noir elements in
there we wanted to limit the palette
give you things that you could focus on
composition is key and by taking out the
colors we're able to focus you in on the
composition of the places the textures
the materials they come out a lot more
and then when you're also seeing is we
mix in that normal because if you don't
give people if you give people just too
much strange that it just automatically
goes into Fantasyland bright having a
place that you know you feel like you've
walked through you feel like you've been
in and then then opening that up we can
sort of turn the water up slowly on the
player and yeah and there and when it
builds up from inside they get more
creeped out as they go because you you
just start to see how it's no it can't
be real anymore but it happens slowly
enough that you've I just get freaked
out by it
would you like it at ulta like that
Silent Hill dichotomy where it's like
you're in familiar places and familiar
buildings and then everything takes it
yes yes that is terrifying that just
sounds awful so were there any
difficulties related to developing for
VR that you hadn't experienced and the
you know platforms and could you expend
I'm not sure it's all a lot of it's the
motion model yeah how are we gonna move
through this world right um for the last
year and a half I don't think many
people knew how yet it was going to be
absolutely we're the best ways to be
inside the world what's the best way to
interact in the world and so you'd see a
lot of articles on people suggesting
things things they thought were gonna
work but nobody knew yet and so there
was a lot of experimentation used to
joke we need her VR merit badges cuz
it's a you know you you'd be trying you
you've definitely felt like you were on
the frontier of something yeah you're
trying something that people didn't know
what to do and how to do it yet it's a
lot of fun because you're you are on the
frontier you're trying something new so
we've learned a lot we've we've done
lots of tests on on how the player moves
what's they're comfortable with what
builds up some of the issues that people
have had in the early stages of VR and
so we have a lot of solves
for that some of our movement the way we
have our comfort turns these are things
that are there to help the play
experience the game stay immersed in the
game
but at the same time very comfortable
and been happy with III because we've
been able to watch a lot of people play
and I think the results have borne out
that we're on the right track we still
have time we're gonna be spending you
know all the time to the last second
continuing to refine that motion model
and make sure that players you know can
stay stay in it for a long time and stay
immersed because that's just really a
great place what kind of feedback have
you seen from people playing at e3 does
anyone like scream like has there been
any like the worst thing I saw was
somebody who literally fell out of his
chair and I was worried for him for a
second he just he rocked back just to
that and then the the chair started to
tip yeah but for so there are some
things that we see what we also see is
the people's comfort in moving we we're
used to it and so we move around a lot
so we've interesting to watch how people
who haven't played it very much
right they are still wanting to use the
controller they still want to they still
want to play more traditionally and
they're not quite ready yet to really
use their whole head and traps to move
around and and that's it that's an
important part of it it's like to
recognize you have that full range of
motion and that it's a big part of it
so what technically is the navigation
scheme you've gone for for getting plays
through the worlds what are we using the
the the default one is what we call
comfort mode where where the head looks
the bodies go so it's sort of like
you're gonna walk if you're walking
forward but the Attic you're looking
this way you're gonna start to move this
way problem a lot of times in horror you
want to turn around quickly though and
yeah that case we have on the right
stick you're doing these turns these
discrete turns where you're rotating
around but we add in a fade to black
between each turn that limits some of
the challenges that players have
experienced and most people between
those two things and looking around they
they navigate the world excellently I
would gather that it must be sort of
slow paced like you would kind of be
working your way through gradually so I
mean or is it like got a lot of quick
sections cuz that's one of the things
with VR that a lot of people having
difficulty with is like you have a game
like
rigs or something and it's such fast
movement people are finding it difficult
to not get wick yeah it VR you mentioned
at the beginning and it's and it is true
VR and horror are a great pairing and
they're and for multiple reasons and one
of them is the fact that you're in the
world and you're scared and you're in
the place and that that strengthens the
horror but also there's a lack of agency
for in good hor the player doesn't have
a lot of or in movies that the character
you don't have a lot of options they
don't you know they don't get a fight
back too much they don't have a lot of
options to and controls by limiting by
limiting the pace by doing things that
are about making the player feel fragile
or not you know not on par with the
challenges they experience you increase
their fear and their discomfort but
you're also aiding in the player's
ability to navigate through the world it
actually feeds itself feeds each other
to the better experience so it actually
plays off really well yeah so yeah we do
limit some of your pacing yeah and it's
for the fear but it also really helps on
on how the player feels yeah is there a
lot of exploration or you're kind of
funneling plays more into the story that
you want them to see as you want them to
say it well there's certainly some
offshoots and there's some past the
player is going to take but it is an
experiential narrative driven game so
there is more about the experiencing the
core story we want to create a dense
experience for the player so while there
going to be some offshoots and past
they're gonna take they're gonna still
they're gonna keep on being funneled
towards the main right I'd also love to
talk about I mean I know you want to
keep everything quiet a little bit but I
did want to ask if you're sharing about
the gameplay are we talking the kind of
gameplay am I going to be armed or am I
just gonna be scared and high because
they come back a little bit more just
like an adventure no there are character
in the world and they will they will
they're gonna happen yeah but I don't
want to get too much into yeah because
there's there part of what the players
can experience you there's a little bit
in the demo so that that's fine yeah but
it is definitely about your taking on
the world and understanding what the
elements are there's a lot in the store
and in the and in the extra details for
you to figure out why you're here what
it's about what is Dana about and that's
the key elements the other things those
characters will be challenging you
they'll be getting they'll be
confronting you with with difficult
choices and decisions that the player is
going to have to make that will make you
uncomfortable and that's a that's a big
part of the control as well that the
player has well this sounds absolutely
fascinating I can't wait so it's down on
the show floor it is on the show on the
show floor you can play it in the psvr
section yeah it's it's right there
that's amazing gotta go and we begin
Alexa and I about terrified of horror
games but it's like it's just like a
masochism it's just I gotta do it anyway
thank you so much for making it so it
can be verified thank you for joining us
we are going to go to a break and then
we're going to be back to talk about
Skylanders but thank you so much for
joining us and we will be back with you
in a moment
you